As we discussed in our article on what happens
to
a person who is accidentally declared dead
and the process in getting declared alive
again, tens of thousands of people die each
year across the globe by a simple clerical
error, at least as far as their respective
governments are concerned.
However, what we didn’t mention is that
many thousands more people are more purposefully
declared “dead in absentia” each year.
As you’ve probably surmised from the term
used to describe these deaths, being declared
dead in absentia occurs after a person goes
missing.
When this happens, their will is probated
and estate settled.
But what happens if they aren’t dead at
all and turn up later, perhaps after helping
a tempestuous, but lovable bunch of vertically
challenged individuals reclaim their homeland
from the clutches of the Chiefest and Greatest
of Calamities?
How do they go about getting their stuff back,
or do they even have any rights to it at all
anymore?
To begin with, how does one go about getting
declared “dead in absentia” in the first
place?
After all, in most countries adults are perfectly
within their rights to uproot and go start
a new life somewhere else without telling
anyone, or even go on a lengthy adventure
with a wizened grey wanderer.
Before we jump into the meat of all this,
just a quick note, as this particular topic
deals with estate distribution and the like,
we’ll focus primarily on adults who disappear,
though many elements of what we’re about
to cover does also technically apply to children.
As with many things, there’s no uniform,
worldwide policy concerning what exact set
of circumstances need occur or even how long
a person needs to be missing to be declared
dead in absentia, though there are many similarities
in the process from country to country.
In general, the courts will have to be directly
involved in these cases and they will almost
always err towards presuming the person is
actually alive.
However, if the person has been missing for
a specific length of time, with no one who
would otherwise normally hear from them having
contact, and a diligent (unsuccessful) search
has been conducted to find them, the courts
will ultimately determine that the person
indeed must be deceased, even if there is
no direct, hard evidence that they are, in
fact, dead.
As to the search, to dispel a popular notion
frequently perpetuated by Hollywood, a person
does not have to be missing for more than
24 hours before authorities in most countries
will act.
In fact, while almost all missing person cases
are resolved of their own accord in relatively
short order, in rare more legitimate missing
person cases, every hour that passes reduces
the probability that said missing person will
be found and nobody is more aware of this
than the authorities who deal with this stuff
every day.
Thus, they often actually recommend reporting
missing people as soon as the person is determined
to be missing.
That said, given there is only so much manpower
available at any given time and, again, most
missing person cases resolve themselves of
their own accord rather quickly, the appropriate
authorities do have to prioritize what cases
they take on immediately.
Thus, rather than strictly going by how much
time has passed before an investigation is
opened, they’ll weight a number of factors
including the probability that the person
is truly missing, and not just off doing something
without telling anyone.
If the disappearance is highly unusual given
the person’s normal daily habits and no
good explanation can be thought up for the
disappearance, this will bump the case up
in the priority list as a potential legitimate
missing person case.
Just as important in getting the authorities
to look into the matter immediately is the
probability that the person missing might
be in some sort of peril given the known facts
of the case.
Once an investigation is started, if nobody
in the person’s life seems to have heard
from them or knows where they are, authorities
usually resort to monitoring the person’s
digitally trackable life, for example where
applicable monitoring financial accounts,
cell phone, email, social media accounts,
etc., as well as checking if the person has
attempted to go through any border check points.
As you might imagine, disappearing without
a trace in the modern world has become increasingly
difficult, meaning these days authorities
are much more frequently able to locate the
person if they are indeed still alive, compared
to even just a few decades ago.
It also helps that many people who are choosing
to disappear from their previous lives are
not trying to hide from authorities, so the
use of personal bank accounts and the like
tends to continue.
If they are found, the authorities will typically
respect the person’s right to disappear
from a former life, unless there are legal
reasons not to, such as someone running from
financial obligations or the like.
As Miranda Napier of the Missing Persons Bureau
notes,
If someone has elected to leave their friends
and family… and we find them and they express
this wish, then we would close the missing
report and advise those making it that they
were safe and well, but we would not be able
to tell them where they were.
Speaking of financial obligations, when trying
to decide if some missing person might actually
be dead, authorities will also analyze whether
the person missing might have had motive to
go missing in the first place.
For example, if they were having extreme financial
difficulties, were in legal trouble, having
relationship or family problems, etc.
As they move along in the process, authorities
will also usually check with local coroners
to see if any unidentified bodies have been
found that match the description of the missing
person.
But what about if all of this turns up nothing?
Next, it becomes a waiting game.
In regards to the length of time needed, as
noted, this varies, but a commonly observed
rule of thumb is that the person has to have
been missing for at least 7 years, unless
circumstances of their disappearance seem
to indicate imminent peril, thus a high probability
that the person is, in fact, deceased.
For example, many bodies couldn’t be identified
or recovered when the World Trade Center towers
collapsed on 9/11, so people who worked there
who went missing directly after would have
an extremely high probability of being declared
dead in absentia almost immediately should
their loved ones request such of the courts.
Few cases are so cut and dry, however, and
in all cases you generally need to get a judge
to agree with you, with the burden of proof
lying with the people trying to get someone
declared dead earlier than the required number
of years.
The judge in these cases will then determine
if, given the evidence, the probability has
shifted from presuming the person is alive
to it being reasonable to presume they are
dead, again usually erring on the side of
assuming the person is still alive.
As former assistant attorney general of Illinois,
Floyd Perkins notes, “Before seven years,
anyone who wants you declared legally dead
has to offer evidence that you’re not alive.
But after you’ve been missing seven years,
anyone who wants you declared alive has to
offer evidence that you’re not dead.”
As for more specifics, in the United States
the authority to declare someone dead in absentia
falls to the states themselves, each of which
have their own specific rules.
For example, while most states go with the
seven year general rule, states like Georgia
and Minnesota instead go with four years.
Moving around to the other side of the world,
in Italy, it actually takes 20 years for someone
to be declared dead in absentia, barring compelling
evidence to decree this sooner.
In Poland, the time span is 10 years.
In Russia, it’s 5.
Like in many states in the U.S. and many other
parts of the world, in the UK, there is a
7 year waiting period before the authorities
can make this call.
It should be noted here that until the authorities
declare the person dead, the missing person’s
financial affairs are basically in a state
of bureaucratic limbo.
To illustrate the issues here, consider the
case of Vicki Derrick, a woman whose husband
Vinny went missing in 2003.
After an investigation to locate Vinny turned
up nothing, he was presumed missing by the
police.
The problem was that in the eyes of the law
Vicki’s husband was still alive and, thus,
she was still married to him with all obligations
that implies, still shared a mortgage on a
house she could no longer afford with just
a single income, but could also not sell because
her husband wasn’t around to put his signature
on the necessary paperwork to sell it.
Furthermore, Vickie couldn’t claim her husband’s
life insurance policy nor access his personal
accounts to settle his various financial obligations
until the courts finally decided enough time
had passed to declared him dead in 2011.
In a bizarre twist, Vinny’s body was found
just two months after he was finally declared
dead in absentia.
As Vicki would later recount,
There was a huge sense of relief, which I
felt guilty about.
But at the same time I had already grieved.
Deep down I think I knew the day he disappeared
he wasn’t coming back.
It was so out of character that something
terrible must have happened for him not to
come home.
It turns out that in the UK alone, while about
98% of the 250,000 or so people that go missing
each year turn up within a week of their disappearance,
about 1% of these people go missing for at
least a year.
In a little over half of these 1% cases, the
person is ultimately either found dead or
eventually declared dead in absentia, but
the other half, over 1,000 missing people
annually, turn up alive in the end.
As a direct result of cases like these, the
government passed the Guardianship (Missing
Persons) Act in 2017 which, 90 days after
the disappearance of the individual, allows
the loved ones of a missing person to assume
some degree of control over their affairs.
Thanks to this, many of the problems people
like Vickie faced can be avoided, mitigating
the potential damage to a missing person’s
financial situation as well as providing a
degree of help in cutting through a lot of
red tape for their loved ones during a tumultuous
time.
No such nationwide laws exist in the United
States and, thus, for example if any benefits
would otherwise have been paid, the beneficiaries
involved usually simply have to wait the required
period for the death in absentia to be declared
before they can begin receiving them, assuming
they can’t offer a sufficient body of evidence
to get the person declared dead early.
Alright, so that’s how you could potentially
be declared dead and have your estate pass
to others without actually being dead.
So let’s now talk about your stuff.
In a nutshell, a person declared dead in absentia
is, by the letter of the law, dead.
Shocker, I know.
As such, the actual process of probating their
will is functionally identical to a more straightforward
death in most countries.
Likewise, death benefits will similarly be
paid out in a timely manner, though some insurers
may require a person making a claim in these
cases to jump through a few additional hoops,
such as providing evidence a good faith effort
was made to locate the person before death
in absentia was declared.
With this information being necessary to declare
a person dead in absentia anyway in most cases,
this usually is a pretty easy hurdle to jump
over at that stage of the game.
But let’s say after all this happens the
“dead” person turns up very much alive
and wants all their stuff back from the clutches
of the Sackville Baggins.
What happens then?
This is a far more thorny legal issue and
there’s little universal precedent in law
to say what exactly should happen, though
in the vast majority the court cases we could
found, the heirs typically weren’t required
to give anything back.
In the US especially what happens in this
unlikely scenario varies slightly from state
to state, with some dictating that the person
has no right to any of their stuff back and
others adding caveats, including Pennsylvania
who deals with the matter perhaps most sensibly
of any region we looked at.
Another example of a state with a caveat is
Nevada, where a missing person has up to a
year after legal proceedings to divide up
the estate have begun to veto the whole thing
and get their money and property back, despite
having been previously declared dead in absentia.
If a missing person turns up after this grace
period, they will no longer have any claim
to their former assets.
To give the missing person as much of a chance
as possible to prevent this from happening
if they are indeed still alive, a person laying
claim to the estate to the missing person
in this case must “give notice by publication”.
This mostly just means doing something like
putting an ad in a local paper or the like
that they are going to make a claim on the
estate, which is sure to be read by no one
but the intern who processed the notice, but
at least gives the appearance of accomplishing
something, so is a bureaucrat’s dream law.
Moving on to Pennsylvania, the state law very
sensibly requires anyone laying claim to a
person’s estate who has been declared dead
in absentia to secure a refunding bond before
assets will be distributed.
As Pennsylvania-based attorney Patti Spencer
states, “The person entitled, a spouse or
kid, has to post a refunding bond, before
the property is distributed.
If the person comes back… and someone else
has her property, they have to give it back,
and if they can’t, then this bonding company
has to make it right.”
This is something that happened relatively
recently as 2013 when a woman named Brenda
Heist returned after her presumed death in
2003.
She’d actually been living on the street
for the last decade and hadn’t even been
aware she had been declared dead.
UK law, as with many other countries we looked
at, seems to more or less handle things about
the same as the general U.S. court systems.
If the person has been declared dead in absentia
and sufficient time has passed, which is usually
needed to get declared dead in absentia in
the first place, the courts will usually rule
that the heirs aren’t required to give anything
back, though, of course, any heirs are free
to do so at their own discretion.
The courts simply usually won’t require
them to do so if a lawsuit is raised over
the matter, though, as with all things in
life, their are exceptions.
But what about life insurance and various
death benefits?
As you might imagine, the insurance companies
will almost always seek to get their money
back, unless the cost to do so exceeds the
amount paid out.
But from whom do they try to get the money
back from?
While, as with so much of what we’ve just
discussed it’s not universally true, if
a missing person’s loved ones have them
declared dead in absentia and then claim against
their life insurance policy in good faith
(and thus aren’t involved in any fraud here),
they won’t generally be sued for the money
back, or, even if they are, the courts are
unlikely to side with the insurance company
in these cases.
The life insurance companies tend to have
much better luck going after the person who
was incorrectly declared dead in absentia.
After all, the missing person knows they are
still alive and usually went missing on purpose,
setting off the chain of events that required
the insurance company to eventually pay out
on a policy when they otherwise shouldn’t
have been obligated if the missing person
had just told someone they weren’t dead.
For example, consider the case of John Burney
who disappeared, in this case in a way that
made it seem very likely he was dead, in 1976
after getting in some rather hot water owing
to mismanagement of his company, causing it
to go bankrupt.
About six years later, in 1982, he was found
to be alive when he decided to return home
to visit his father who had been seriously
injured.
Although Burney’s insurance company initially
filed suit against the beneficiaries of his
life insurance policy – specifically his
wife and business partners – the courts
ruled that they didn’t have to return the
money.
Burney, however, who didn’t receive a dime
of that insurance money, did, to the tune
of $470,000 (about $1.2 million today).
So to sum up, if you do happen to mysterious
disappear and then turn up again after being
declared dead, chances are your stuff will
be gone unless your beneficiaries are feeling
particularly generous and choose on their
own to give it back.
And should they have cashed in on a life insurance
policy you had, assuming they really thought
you were dead when they did it, you are likely
going to be the one on the hook to pay that
back, even if you didn’t benefit from it
in any way.
To add insult to injury, particularly if you
live in the United States, prepare yourself
for quite the lengthy ordeal in getting yourself
declared alive again in the first place, with
a number of rather severe consequences while
you try to prove to everyone that you are,
in fact, not dead.
Thus, unfortunately for the owner of a certain
estate along Bagshot Row, given his disappearance
most definitely was out of the ordinary for
his normal behavioral patterns and, beyond
that, he was last seen, at least in the film
adaptation, noting he was “going on an adventure”
(always a dodgy business), in either case
those seeking his estate seem perfectly within
their rights to have had him declared dead
in absentia.
Assuming Shire law did not have a grace period
for legal right to recover an estate after
such
a declaration, like Nevada,